[Music]
on this Thursday night urgent calls for
countries to take steps to slow the
spread of Kovac 19 I speak with the
Canadian doctor playing a key role and
just returned from China the most
critical thing here is speed why he says
worst-case scenario planning is
essential and a mystery of why some
young adults die from the virus plus the
push to help workers force to stay home
dialing down the cost of cell phone
plans
Ottawa's ultimatum to big telecom plus a
Quebec Rail blockade removed for now let
this be a strong message and
demonstration of good faith to all of
Canada and the natural gas project in
Canada in jeopardy
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with fast-moving developments
in the corona virus there are now more
than 97 thousand cases of koban 19
worldwide and the Canadian doctor who is
the assistant director of the World
Health Organization says now is the time
for countries to pull out all the stops
we're seeing evidence that this can
actually be contained and controlled but
we're not seeing that effort to contain
and control to keep pace with the spread
so we're right at a tipping point where
the commitment of governments and
countries to really get on top of this
is got to be crucial in the coming few
days and weeks that's dr. Bruce Aylward
he's just returned from studying the
outbreak in China I spoke with him today
about what he learned there about the
virus how it spreads and who it kills
that's coming up first though the
numbers Canada now has 12 new cases that
includes the first presumptive case just
announced in Alberta a Calgary woman in
her 50s who was on the Grand Princess
cruise ship will tell you more about
that in a moment too if her test is
confirmed it means a total of 46 in
Canada BC has eight new cases half are
connected to previously identified cases
and linked to travel to Iran one though
is a woman who hasn't traveled and had
no known contact with anyone who did it
appears to be the first case of
community transmission in Canada the
other cases are in Ontario and two
others are in Quebec in the u.s. 18
states have now detected the virus most
have just one or two cases but in
California and Washington State there
are clusters of illness South Korea
Italy and Iran are still a hardest hit
in China where this outbreak began new
infections have slowed dramatically in
the past two weeks
around the world there are nearly ninety
eight thousand confirmed cases and more
than 3,300 deaths
w-h-o says china appears to have
suppressed the outbreak in Wuhan because
it acted fast and that can be replicated
it says in other countries including
Canada but worst case scenario planning
should be well underway in tonight's top
story David akin looks at whether Canada
is heating that advice among the latest
Kovan 19 cases in Ontario a man in
Toronto just back from Iran and a woman
in Kitchener just back from Italy that's
a new info
first from Italy with what's gone in
Italy I would be expecting some more
some regions of Italy along with China
Iran and South Korea are the world's
kovat 19 hotspots Canada is screening
travelers arriving from those regions
and taking action on a case-by-case
basis but other countries the United
States Indonesia and most notably
Australia have taken a much more
restrictive approach Australia now bans
all foreign nationals arriving from
South Korea China and Iran and
Australian citizens arriving from those
countries
face a mandatory 14-day quarantine no
matter their health condition but Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau said Canada
would stick with its case-by-case
approach there is a lot of
misinformation out there there is a lot
of knee-jerk reaction that isn't keeping
people safe the decisions we make are
based on the best recommendations of the
w-h-o and the tremendous Health Act for
experts who work both in Canada and
around the world
Ontario's top public health officials
said Australia style travel bans may not
work for Canada our experience is that
they only work to eliminate extent as
you can see some countries had strike
quite strong travel bans like the u.s.
like Italy and it didn't prove to be
successful at this time travel bans can
also increase the damage to the economy
and the day after the Bank of Canada's
slashed its key interest rate because of
the economic impact of kovat 19 Bank
governor Stephen poloz cautioned about
the uncertainty ahead we believe we've
done a lot there to cushion a blow we
don't know how big the blow might be so
we'll be looking at ways to figure out
how big that blow might be and how long
it might last that uncertainty weighed
on investors the Dow Jones Industrial
Average fell by more than three and a
half percent Thursday while Canada's
benchmark S&P TSX composite was down by
more than 1.3 percent finally dawnie
it's important to mention that Canada's
public health officials like dr.
Williams continue to say that Canada's
containment system is working and the
risk to public health remains low that
is important David akin in Ottawa
Thanks more new cases have emerged in
Europe and in the UK the first person
has died authorities say an elderly
person with underlying health conditions
is the UK's first kovat 19 victim 25
more people tested positive they're
bringing the total in the UK to 115 the
Prime Minister's official spokesperson
warned today that it's highly likely the
virus is going to spread in a
significant ways in Greece the number of
cases jumped from ten to thirty one for
--'tis have shut down schools and
universities and banned major public
gatherings in parts of Greece for at
least several days similar bans are
already in place in Italy and Iran where
the health care systems are struggling
to cope with thousands of infections and
passengers on board the Grand Princess
cruise ship owned by the same company as
the diamond princess are in limbo
tonight it's being held off the coast of
San Francisco because a man who had been
a passenger has since died of the virus
it's the same ship a Calgary woman was
on she's Alberta's first presumptive
case more than 20 people who are still
on board are showing symptoms as Abigail
Beeman reports among the thousands of
passengers are 235 Canadians they are
bleaching and vinegar a live stream from
two sisters stuck on a cruise off the
coast of San Francisco
I don't want to go along to my family
I don't want to take it to my city if I
happen to have it on my clothes whatever
half the passengers are from California
235 Canadians are aboard - we are going
to be flying testing kits to the cruise
ship and we are going to be sending
those quickly back the first covin 19
death in the state of California was
traced back to a passenger who was
aboard the same ship last month the
governor has issued a state of emergency
joining Florida and Washington state
there an old motel will be turned into a
quarantine facility with at least 10
deaths and a new spike in the number of
cases and New York saw its number of
cases double Thursday what ends up
happening is that there's a friend of
the person who's in the hospital and
that person has a friend and then they
have family and relatives but in a Fox
News interview Wednesday the American
president questioned the World Health
Organization's official death rate I
think that three point four percent is
really false number now this is just my
hunch it's because a lot of people will
have this and it's very mild personally
I would say the number is way under 1%
medical experts expect the number of US
cases to climb further once more tests
are done we don't have enough tests
today to meet what we anticipate will be
the demand going forward American
officials previously promised a million
tests would be available by the end of
next week
meanwhile lawmakers here approved eight
point three billion dollars in emergency
spending to combat the outbreak abigail
Beeman Global News Washington there is
an upgraded Travel Warning from the
Canadian government tonight Canadians
are now being told to avoid all travel
to Iran the country is dealing with one
of the worst kovin 19 outbreaks outside
China people coming to Canada from
around and from Hubei Province in China
are being asked to voluntarily self
isolate for two weeks when they get here
Mike drily explains how self isolation
and social distancing can help limit the
spread
it was jarring to see Canadians
returning from Wuhan China quarantined
at CFB Trenton but while it may have
stoked fears of an outbreak of kovat 19
none of those who lived in isolation for
14 days were infected by the virus it
was a precaution similar to when Marilyn
and Tom shook returned to Saskatchewan
from a February cruise in the East China
Sea and were told they needed to self
isolate so they did voluntarily
we weren't quarantined it would be
different if we had the disease I don't
know what they would have done if we
would have told them no we're gonna go
around waiver health officials have
three options here in Canada isolation
for patients who are infected but they
can also ask people like the Shooks to
self isolate as a precaution so it's a
broad term quarantine which restricts
the movement of people who may have been
exposed but are not yet sick and social
distancing which prevents people from
congregating in large crowds the public
health infrastructure does have the
power to do all sorts of things that
normally you would not do to people
we've seen social distancing in other
countries the Japanese baseball league
is playing as preseason games and empty
stadiums and there are discussions to
postpone the season outright and in the
NBA players have been told to refrain
from high-fiving fans and no more
autographs but most pressing for
Canadians right now is what happens if
you need to stay home politicians in
Ontario Nova Scotia are pushing for
temporary measures whereby employees
would not have to get a doctor's note as
well as ways to offset the potential for
lost income they've warned the current
provincial labor laws are quote a
serious threat to the health and safety
of Ontarians the idea is to make
self-isolation less burdensome because
nobody should have to feel like they're
fighting this alone microlight Global
News Toronto in other news tonight one
of the last remaining rail blockades in
this country has come down Mohawks on
the gonna walk a reserve in Quebec had
been blocking the tracks for almost four
weeks after debate within the gonna walk
a community and discussions with what so
it in hereditary Chiefs in BC the
protesters removed
blockade this afternoon our Mike
Armstrong was there the sacred fire that
had burned for 28 days at the rail
blockade in Ghana [ __ ] a has been moved
early Thursday afternoon it was
relocated as the procession crossed the
highway mohawks explained they have
removed the blockade to take pressure
off the situation in BC the relocation
is a gesture of good faith as that were
true within hereditary keish are now
taking the time to deliberate on the
proposed agreement the fire will
continue to burn as a sign it'll be
visible on the side of the highway to
thousands of cars that pass through the
reserve a message that the blockade can
go up again we will be closely
monitoring the situation and with sue
attend as well as other indigenous
communities another blockade in eastern
Quebec is still up Micmacs and lista
goosh have been blocking rails in
solidarity with with Soudan for 25 days
they say they're in consultation
debating whether to remove it it is an
opportunity to make the most of Western
Canada's existing natural gas surpluses
the blockades over a pipeline in BC may
kill a natural gas project in Quebec the
promoter behind a plan to build a nine
and a half billion dollar LNG terminal
in saguenay says its biggest backer is
pulling out the reports Warren Buffett
is that backer through his investment
company Berkshire Hathaway the reason
according to the promoter instability
and challenges in the current Canadian
political context Mike Armstrong global
news nagi Quebec the Manitoba government
is changing course and will introduce
its own carbon tax it will be $25 per
tonne and it will start on Canada Day to
help offset the cost premier Brian
Pallister says he'll lower the
provincial sales tax by one point to 6
percent Ottawa has imposed a carbon tax
of $20 a ton on Manitoba and three other
provinces and it will rise to $50 by
2022 Pallister is fighting that tax in
court and says he's trying to protect
people from the escalating pricing
scheme he says Manitoba's changes could
save the average household five hundred
and twenty five dollars
per year there is an ugly fight over
migrants on the border between Turkey
and Greece Turkey has deployed 1,000
police officers Greek police are firing
tear gas stun grenades in water cannon
they're trying to stop the migrants from
crossing Turkey claims Greek police have
even fired live ammunition and have
killed at least four migrants
Greece denies that huge numbers of
people including children are trapped in
this they're outside they're hoping to
make the journey to Europe Turkey is
allowing the mass exodus from its
country saying it can no longer afford
to support the millions of refugees who
have fled the war in Syria the
International Criminal Court has ruled
an investigation into alleged war crimes
by Americans and others in Afghanistan
can go ahead the prosecutor says the
court has enough information to prove US
forces had committed what it calls acts
of torture cruel treatment outrages upon
personal dignity rape and sexual
violence in Afghanistan this overturns a
previous decision that blocked the
investigation the actions of the Taliban
the Afghan government and American
troops since May of 2003 are expected to
be examined still ahead Ottawa's call
two big telecom safe customers money or
else a warning today to Canada's three
big cellphone companies from the federal
government they have two years to slash
their prices to customers by 25% or the
government says it will take action to
increase competition for years Canadian
cell phone prices have been among the
highest in the world telecom companies
are warning if they slash prices
they'll have to slash jobs to Mike look
at or reports nearly nine and ten
Canadians own a cell phone according to
a recent government survey 95% of those
people say pricing on mobile plans are
worse compared to other countries and 83
percent of people don't think their plan
has gotten cheaper in the last three
years following through on a campaign
promise the federal government is
stepping in we expect the big three to
reduce their prices by 25
sent in the next two years the
subscribers could save as much as $15 a
month the big telecom companies point
out prices in this country have come
down in recent months however stats show
they remain among the highest in the
world and if telcos won't comply within
two years the Minister is promising to
flex some regulatory muscle we will look
at additional regulatory measures like
how we deploy future spectrum or mobile
virtual network operators as a means to
drive more competition which will help
lower prices to create more competition
one quarter of the new 5g spectrum is
being opened to smaller and regional
companies but the CEO of Telus already
warned that could mean cuts in the
vicinity of a billion dollars of reduced
investment over the next five years the
reduced employment is in the zip code of
5,000 jobs consumer advocates applaud
the price decrease but say Canada still
has a long way to go let's put some
brakes on me the runaway Canadian train
of pricing but it's not a it's not going
to resemble the US or European markets
for quite some time while announcing the
next step in the 5g network the Liberal
government isn't saying who's going to
build it international partners of warn
Canada not to use Huawei because of
security concerns but both Minister
Bane's and Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
said no decision has been made yet
Mike lacouture global news Ottawa
critical lessons a Canadian doctor
returns from China his diagnosis of the
koban 19 outbreak next
as we wait to see what happens next with
the coronavirus a Canadian doctor has a
front-row seat dr. Bruce Aylward is
assistant director-general with the
World Health Organization he and a team
just spent two weeks in China studying
how that country suppressed the Cova
Denine teen outbreak restricting it
largely to the city of Wuhan and the
surrounding province it is now spreading
faster outside China than inside that
country dr. l-word thanks so much for
joining us this is such a fast evolving
situation the numbers change by the hour
you're among a handful of people
watching this more closely than anyone
else in the world what's your assessment
of where we're at with this virus well
we're at a pretty critical point right
now because we're at a point where we're
seeing a rapid international spread as
one would anticipate with a virus like
this we're seeing evidence that this can
actually be contained and controlled but
we're not seeing that effort to contain
and control to keep pace with the spread
so that we're right at a tipping point
where the commitment of governments and
countries to really get on top of this
is going to be crucial in the coming few
days and weeks what is the most critical
thing right now the most critical thing
here Donna is speed test them quickly
and then know whether or not they have
to be isolated so it spreads similar to
the way of flu but there are differences
and that provides us a little window to
if we move very fast in a country to be
able to find it quickly and contain the
cases or isolate them find their close
contacts and stop what we call
transmission chains and that can prevent
an awful lot of damage what do we know
specifically about the transmission of
this virus there's some really important
things we know Donna the most important
is that the vast majority of the
transmission is going to be driven by
people who have the symptoms as well as
they're very close contacts and most of
it is going to be occurring in areas
where you've got prolonged exposures in
in close proximity in families you know
in a cubicle maybe at work dr. Elbert
who is most vulnerable we know the
elderly and people with underlying
health issues are dying from it
we've heard of cases where younger
people get it and die - what did you
learn about that in China there's a lot
of 30 year olds 40 year olds 50 year
olds who get this disease they're very
healthy and they die and they die
quickly sometimes we don't know why
these people are deteriorating so it's a
big still unanswered question and it's a
really important one because that would
help us obviously tackle this and this
is a key question for parents what about
children getting it it looks like
children have a more and generally a
more mild form of the disease now they
can they'll get sick and they can die
but at a much lower frequency Canada is
ramping up preparations what do you make
of Canada's response it's impressive
after SARS you built a public health
care system that knows how to find cases
investigate them follow their contacts
and manage them properly because you're
not seeing clusters of outbreaks around
these cases do you think it's too much
or inappropriate for countries to do
worst-case scenario planning you have to
plan for for worst-case scenarios and
you want to tell your population here's
what we're gonna do if we have
individual cases here's what we're gonna
do if we start having clusters here's
what we're going to do if we have
widespread community transmission
because you have to bring your
population with you they're the key
doctor Aylward from the World Health
Organization thanks so much for taking
the time to talk to us my pleasure thank
you very much Donna he's been working so
hard for weeks that is global national
for this Thursday I'm dawn or freezing
tonight Sierra Canada is Henderson Lake
in Lethbridge Alberta we'd love to see
your Canada please email it to us and
thanks for watching hope to see you here
again tomorrow
bye-bye
[Music]